hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast from
Monday May 11th 2020 what's going on how
ya how's it going oh it's the pandemic
it's never gonna end
it's the pandemic look at your friend is
he wearing a mask if he's not kicking me
yes
[Music]
he's stupid [__] it's [__]
unbelievable every day not now this like
traffic out here in LA there's more and
more people being just like well [__]
this [__] and everybody's just going out
it's on its this whole [__] thing
should have been over in a month if
everybody did what the [__] they told
him to do but no everybody has to get in
their ego masks don't apply to me this
is all a big [__] scam to bring down
Trump I don't I don't understand it I
don't [__] you out with a head out in
Pasadena a bunch of young stupid [__]
kids had a big party out there and some
[__] party goer was coughing who who
would have it and the douche did so now
they got a new bunch of breakouts out
there just [__] idiots and and I
don't know what how come they don't go
to jail how come they don't get arrested
how come they they don't get [__]
sent we need to create Corona Island
Cove it 19 Island and if you get this
[__] past a certain [__] date then
you're just a douche walking around
without a mask take you out of the
[__] Popeye there's no solution
there's no solution I don't know I don't
know what what the [__] to do here that
god bless the [__] people working on
a cure I yelled at my first person he
completely ignored me I was walking
around you know the block with my
daughter we both had masks on or
whatever and I just hid this person
walking quickly behind me I turn around
this it's a [__] older guy no masks
on and I'm thinking all right well he's
going to take a wide
right he goes to walk right by so I
walked up a driveway no psych-k buddy
where's your mask ignores me where's
your valium rules don't apply to you hi
oh man you wanna dance a few rounds this
quarantine has me yelling at old people
I don't know do you guys have any
solutions does anybody have any theories
as to why people would are there must be
way more trust fund kids out there than
then I thought I would think on some
level even as a young person you would
be concerned you know what happened his
kids became friends with their parents
that's what happened you know we went
from [__] go upstairs and get my belt
overcorrected too you know now like
parents are smoking weed with their kids
that [__] generation that dumbass
generation hey you know you guys want to
do some [__] what do they call those
Bob it's you it's what I think what's
this [__] that just took everybody out
you wanna do some oxy I'd rather have my
kid - oxy with me than with others I
don't know I don't I don't get these
[__] parents just letting their kids
just running all over the place doing
order the [__] do I don't know if that's
even [__] true I don't even III don't
know I'm just making up [__] you know
I'm just making up [__] playing drums
podcasting zooming losing my mind like
everybody else and watching a bunch of
[__] on old football so let's talk about
old football as as as the selfish [__]
maybe even some selfish constant
listening to this podcast who like your
community but you go do good police yoga
gig whatever the [__] they're saying Oh
gives a [__] I'm actually starting to
hope that this thing morphs into a
deadly virus and all these [__]
doshas walking out there who think
they're too [__] good to follow the
[__] rules
who won't be team players all get [__]
taken out that's what I would love one
of those like a [__] Australian snake
the old twelve step drop thing yeah
that's that's what it is he I was all
with this we're all into this together
yadda yadda yadda now I'm just like you
know what I hope these [__] [__] die
every [__] one of you [__] out there
sunbathing you know having birthday
parties and all of that [__] I hope you
all [__] die how about that there you
go what somebody else is gonna have to
lose their [__] home in the next
[__] couple of months because you
want to go out and do [__] Jazzercise
in a park it's ridiculous and that
[__] dope Donald Trump why doesn't he
bring that up he's so [__] stupid
he's so busy saying what a great [__]
job he did there's nothing to apologize
for it caught everybody everybody's
[__] country was [__]
alright so [__] all the Liberals coming
at you saying all that [__] you got to
go after these cuts not wearing their
[__] masks a bunch of [__] babies
I don't know my my opinion on [__]
humanity I really need to fix it here
because I'm stiii try to act like most
people are cool which I still think they
are but I'm telling you the amount of
dopes when we somehow come out of this
[__] thing the amount of [__]
dopes who are living week to week and
I'm not talking about broke people poor
people racism sexism and all that [__]
that prevents people from moving ahead
and I'm not talking about that [__] I'm
talking about perfectly good white
people okay who can walk into any office
as [__] directions to where the
[__] job interview is at least be
heard okay you [__] dopes who are
making enough money where you can
actually save some so the next time some
[__] like this happens you're not
sitting there with the pockets turned
inside out after eight [__] days the
amount of you who are going to continue
to buy the next flat screen TV [__]
iPad and all of that [__] I really hope
you don't I really hope you don't well
what am I going to look at during the
pandemic
I don't have any answers people I just
just stay inside for a [__] month
Jesus this is like watching an addict
trying to get sober it starts tomorrow
it starts tomorrow your whole [__]
life goes by anyway so I've been reading
a bunch of [__] on old school football
right and what the hell am i here so I
was I was watching my sister wrong one
that is the wrong one I got I got all of
this [__] [__] that I looked up ere
it is there it is okay I was looking I
was watching some old Floyd little
number 44 in your program from the
Denver Broncos I always loved his name
when I first got into football I used to
I used to I used to check out books on
football from the library
my parents be like I only go get a book
smart yeah right and then I would come
out with a book about the [__] 1971
Washington Redskins right so I used to
always see all this stuff on floydlittle
and I was fascinated with these guys
that played before the people I was now
watching so I'm watching Floyd little
highlights which I highly recommend and
in the middle of it a couple of times I
see him catching passes from a black
quarterback and they showed him quickly
I was like let's had a black quarterback
those arms did not look white right
number fifteen so I looked the guy up
Marlin Briscoe aka the magician number
15 for the Broncos listen to this
[__] story alright here we go
Marlin Oliver Briscoe nicknamed the
magician is a former American League
football quarterback and wide receiver
in October 1968 after being drafted by
the Denver Broncos of the AFL he in the
fourteenth round by the way he became
the first starting black quarterback in
professional American football and
established a Denver
rookie record of 14 touchdown passes
that season he played professionally for
nine years he's from Omaha Nebraska
which is amazing that he didn't become
an offensive lineman the way they feed
those kids that [__] corn out there
he went to the University of Nebraska at
Omaha okay now check this [__] out
you're like okay so his rookie he set a
record of 14 touchdown passes that
season and he played professionally for
nine years well how come you don't know
about a bill this is why Brisco was a 5
foot 10 177 pounds when the AFL Broncos
drafted him in the 14th round of the
1968 drafted 22 years of age the Broncos
intended to convert Brisco to cornerback
but Brisco had negotiated for a chance
to compete for the quarterback position
tell me this isn't a Denzel movie let me
tell you so Marlon and I know your
quarterback you know them you know the
guy would have to have a southern accent
cuz he's racist that's that's how white
people handle white racism was we just
make it act like it's all down south
play on a ball maybe trying to knock it
down with your jumping ability on
September 29th 1968 after starters Steve
10c suffered a broken collarbone he must
have been on a dirt lake and back up Joe
DeVito was spotty head coach Lew Saban
summoned Brisco from the sidelines in
the fourth quarter against the Boston
Patriots to give him a try Briscoes
first play was a 22 yard completion on
his second series he orchestrated an 80
yard touchdown drive he completed a 21
yard pass and ran for 38 more himself
carrying carrying it the last 12 yards
for the score I mean tell me that right
there wasn't a glimpse into the future
of the quarterback position a week later
on October 6 he became the first
starting african-american quarterback in
the AFL Briscoe through 14 touchdown
passes that year in just five starts
including four on November 29th against
Buffalo both are still Bronco rookie
wreck
he threw for 335 [__] yards in that
game a rookie record that stood until
John Elway broke it in 1983 I bet they
didn't try to make him a cornerback you
can knock it down with your teeth
Johnny and one of only three 300 plus
yard rookie games in franchise history
he completed 41 and a half percent of
his passes and averaged 7.1 yards per
attempt and his 17.1 yards per
completion led the American Football
League and ranks 18th all-time he also
ran for 308 yards and three touchdowns
okay so you would think that this would
at least get him an opportunity to
compete the next year for the
quarterback job now here comes page 2 in
the page 20 of the script before the
1969 season started Brisco still
determined to play quarterback like he
hasn't proved that he should be in
consideration discovered that head Coach
Saban instead it intended to use pete
liske or liske lis ke as the starter so
he asked to be released he went to the
AFL's Buffalo Bills where he was turned
into a receiver
since the bills already had superstar
Jack Kemp former Pro Bowler Tom Flores
and super bowl head coach of the Oakland
Raiders later on in LA Raiders and James
Harris another black quarterback with a
more prototypical six foot four two and
a 10 pound frame Brisco never played
quarterback again is he's like the black
Doug Flutie this is ridiculous the guy's
a winner but he enjoyed a splendid
career he led Buffalo and touchdown
catches each of his three seasons there
and in receptions twice in 1970 he was
in the top two in receptions and
receiving yards and became an all-pro
then amazing then retirement legacy was
a successful businessman got involved in
you know the coke 80s became addicted
but recovered I mean it's a [__] movie
a biopic film titled the Magician based
on Briscoes life has been under
development
several years Canadian actor lyric bent
has been approached to portray Brisco in
the film in 2016 the University of
Nebraska hum up Briscoes Omaha mariscos
alma mana honored him by unveiling a
statue unreal isn't that interesting
here's something else that I face
something else that I found interesting
when I bought some old football cards
from 1969 and I was going through him
and lo and behold the first [__] 20
the first Isley number card number one
is Leroy Kelly number 44 and yet program
he's the guy who had to take over after
Jim Brown he was drafted with Jim Brown
had two years left
I guess people probably didn't know he
had two years left and this guy just
took over like a [__] champ running
for a thousand yards almost every damn
year three years in a row
but I guess the Browns made a couple of
bad trades that [__] I was at the
Giants that [__] up their defense both
the Bryant Browns and the Giants made
some bad trades that led to the 1970s
where they both stunk
Giants turned it around because they had
Parcells with Bill Belichick and the
Browns did not but then the Browns got
Bill Belichick as a head coach with Nick
Saban on that coaching staff and they
decided to fire both of them so there
you go
anyways next guy Jim CAD I'll I'm all I
can say about that guy is he blocked for
Gale Sayers
Eric Barnes well the great quarterbacks
I didn't know anything about him Willie
Richardson poor guy played for the Colts
his whole career the year he lost to the
Jets in the Super Bowl the year he
leaves and goes to the Dolphins the
Colts beat the Cowboys in Super Bowl
five and then he then he was with the
Dolphins and then he came back to the
Colts and when he the [__] Dolphins
won at the air he left bullet Bob Hayes
Bob Jeter I was like is that Derek
Jeter's dad I'm like no he's too [__]
old turns out he was one half of the
greatest quarterbacks for the Green Bay
Packers that won an unprecedented three
titles in a row 65 60
six and sixty seven NFL titles Bob Jeter
on one side her bad early on the other
side then the first Patriot
him call Chloe never heard of the guy he
was part of the Patriots all-decade team
of the 1960's Letterman receiving 'he's
also was part owner of bachelors three
in new york city with the boston bruins
Derek Sanderson and the New York Jets
Broadway Joe it was on the Upper East
Side it was a [__] BA it attracted
athletes celebrities and mobsters so
Pete Rozelle had to step in and tell him
to shut it down because they couldn't be
rubbing elbows with the mobsters because
they thought they'd start throwing some
gigs now if you're into conspiracy
theory they say that the [__]
mobsters were already in bed with the
Colts are some [__] and they threw Super
Bowl three or it was fixed so the NFL
could merged with the AFL who knew I'm
just gonna do the first ten cards
alright
then one of the toughest guys to ever
play according to Hank Stram I swear to
God his first name is Cheryl with an S
Cheryl Hedrick guy refused to wear head
hip pads there's all kinds of stories of
like bones sticking out and Jim just
[__] popping his fingers back in
never missed a snap one of the toughest
guys ever and his name is Cheryl which
then brings me to Jim Dunaway at the
Buffalo Bills now these next two cards
are kind of tragic
Jim Dunaway now this is what I find a
Merritt amazing is that in the AFC East
you have two football teams that had two
players that allegedly committed murder
two on the Patriots two on the Buffalo
Bills and there's the interesting thing
both the players on the Patriots got
convicted Aaron Hernandez that everybody
knows and then there's another guy Eric
Naposki who was an imposing force on the
football field playing for the New
England Patriots and he wasn't he came
up for a cup of coffee was there an 88
and 89 when I had season tickets Eric
Naposki had a successful career
he played 2 years in the NFL and he was
going on May 21st but that's more than
most people do 2009 Eric's life changed
for the worse when he was charged with a
murder that took place in December of
1994 Naposki was charged with killing
Nanette Johnson's boyfriend Bill
mcLaughlin so that Johnson could collect
McLaughlin's life-insurance policy
Naposki was convicted of the crime and
sentenced to life in prison without
parole and there's a crazy twist so was
the girlfriend usually doesn't happen
now the Buffalo Bills now if you're an
NFL player and you feel like committing
murder but you don't want to go to jail
you want to play for the Buffalo Bills I
don't know what kind of lawyers they
have I don't know what what the deal is
here but OJ Simpson we all know got away
with it and then there's a good Jim
Dunaway Jim Dunaway once again another
guy who everybody thinks did it got a I
was acquitted and then his own children
sued him in in a civil suit which he
lost it's amazing so ladies you know
what I mean you don't want to marry a
Buffalo Bill okay because they're gonna
kill you and they're gonna get away with
it they might lose some money though
that makes you feel better so look up
that story his wife was found in a pool
she drowned but they could tell that her
her that was she had bought I might have
spared the detail she had bodily
injuries that they determined happened
before she was placed in the pool and
then drowned and then right after that
because I look up to see if these people
are still alive there's this guy Bill
Munson who played quarterback forever in
the NFL he just kept getting relegated
to he like he backed up like Roman
Gabriel with the Rams or something like
that and then when he got to the the
Lions who the hell was a quarterback
Landry I think he was behind him anyways
he played for a long time they put like
1415 years then unfortunately he went
out had a couple of drinks came home
fell into his pool and that was it
all right so there you go
that's what I learned and I just watched
a whole bunch of the football highlights
and I got myself a nice bunch of
football cards from 1969 and I'm going
through them and I just looked the guys
up I do it on Wikipedia and on the
football reference just because these
football cards
I really like them but I don't like it
they don't have their career stats which
is what I used to love when I was a kid
and this is what I used to look at
instead of doing my multiplication
tables and learning how to spell and all
of that [__]
I had great study habits I just was not
studying anything I was supposed to be
learning yeah and I remember was
convinced I was going to be a a sports
announcer because I had that you know
that little electric game the vibrating
game this is before video games they had
this little thing and you just put these
guys it was so weird and then they had
this one was supposed to be the
quarterback or it through like a
magnetic football that was supposed to
eat the whole [__] thing didn't work
and you just would set the players up
and they would vibrate and move and it
just didn't work and after a while
either was she just never plugged it in
again it was like a like I got like a
griddle except it vibrated right so what
you just end up doing is not using it
and you just play with the players like
you would army guys and invent games so
I would always have the Patriots win and
I and it was all the Patriots from when
I was a kid was there was like Matt
Caron and Jim Plunkett and I had all
those numbers on there John Hannah and I
imagine you know Darryl Stingley and
some of those other guys we had from
back then I was tingling rest in peace
and then the other team I don't know if
was it I don't know what team they were
supposed to be because it was weird with
the licensing back then I want to say it
was the Giants how funny is that our big
nemesis during the Brady years which I
can't believe is now in the past tense
[Music]
it looked like that maybe was demos of
bears I don't know but I had names for
all of them that I just made up
I remember one guy was Billy Jackson he
was the toughest guy to get down and he
would always go ahead and then I would
have the Patriots win him is what the
[__] you did you had nothing you know
and at that my parents sent me was I was
spoiled because they grew up they had
like [__] slingshots in [__] Tom
Sawyer [__] anyway so I had like two
days let's talk some drums here shall we
I actually had two days where I only had
like 45 minutes to play I can't believe
how busy I'd been during all of this but
got to keep the plates spinning I had
two days of the most focused and I don't
even know if the word is practice the
most focused in moving forward god I'm
stupid what's the [__] word most
effective Jesus Christ practices I
back-to-back days and then in the last
couple days it wasn't as good because I
think I was I was doing the same thing I
do want to have a good set as a comic
it's like usually the next night I have
a bad set or not as good as set because
I'm thinking about what I did the night
before rather than just being in the
moment so I loved the results of those
two so then I started comparing the
third date this is gonna happen again is
it going to happen again so of course it
doesn't but I just really slowed
everything down and I've just been
working on one or two things I just been
doing everything that Davey llege told
me I'm finally applying it like it took
me forever to get it and then you know
get a little burned out then you play a
few songs have a good time but ba ba ba
and then you maybe come back to it and I
was actually playing good times bad
times
at 84 BPMS write the songs at 95 I was
like oh my god I'm getting there I'm
getting there it's finally happening and
then I was in such a rush to see if that
wasn't just a fluke I don't think I
warmed up enough or whatever and then
the next day I could barely play it at
78 but I
just like all right don't get frustrated
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah so I'm looking
forward to getting out there in the
garage again today what I'm really
looking forward to is getting back on
stage and doing stand-up but until then
I'm just gonna learn about 1960s
football and play a lot of drums and
guitar but play a little guitar busted
dad out my wife this is the funny my
wife my funniest thing ever like I was
sitting there you know on a plane all
the 80s [__] that I grew up with playing
Cinderella
Bon Jovi wanted dead or alive you know
little Rolling Stones right I like death
[__]
it's acoustic guitar you know seasons of
weather Aerosmith you know just having a
good time and then she just keeps coming
and requesting songs she goes like she
goes why don't you learn more than words
from extreme so it's like well this go I
don't all right so I learned that song
and my brother told me that I needed an
intervention if I learned that [__]
song on guitar and you know what I'm
gonna do now and it's actually you know
I'm not [__] on that group because
both was a Gary Cherone
and Nino Benton Corps I can't remember
their names but very talented people
every once in a while you got to write a
hit you know you got to have a [__]
hit you got to have one for the chicks
all right I gotta look up more than
words I gotta look up these lyrics
because as far as I remember was
basically a guy who didn't want to say I
love you so now he's trying to [__]
know saying I love you is not the words
I want to hear from you it's not that I
want you not to say but if you only knew
how easy it would be to show me how you
feel more than words is all you have to
do to make it real then you wouldn't
have to say that you love me because I'd
already know well yet because you know
what do cuz you don't want to say it to
her listen I'm not don't say you love me
you know you can show it to me and
that'll mean more and I'll
the same to you and I love that the
chicks bought it what would you do if my
heart was torn into more than words to
show you feel that your love for me is
real what would you say if I took those
words away then you couldn't make things
new just by saying I love you either way
the skin maybe he's totally [__]
insecure more than words la dee da da
dee da dee de de da let me tell you
something up more than words there's
more than that [__] going on in that
[__] song
the [__] out of here or maybe he
realizes that he's in love with the
douche and then she does ridiculous
things anything from just being selfish
to [__] around on them and then but
honey I love you love you sorry I love
you
then he should be writing the song he
should be getting the [__] out of the
relationship either way either way
there's so many songs it like you just
you listen to like for [__] decades
and then just one day you finally really
listen to the lyrics you like wait a
minute why what the [__] is this guy
talking about or maybe you're having
these experiences in life and you're
superimposing them onto the lyrics that
these two people wrote and you're 100%
wrong that all all right okay it's time
to do more than teach our DJ D dude
alright LegalZoom everybody sorry now
you guys aren't all gonna have that in
your heads but I'm telling you just
[__] look up the lyrics oh whatever
whatever what would you rather have
would you rather have what the [__] is
that song I was listening to I also like
Cinderella shake me she said shake me
why
she say shake me you give her [__]
whiplash right let's that Chris Rock
been right never hit a woman but I'll
shake the [__] out of him he must have
been a Cinderella Fair legal zone Health
and Safety is on top of everyone's minds
right now no matter what happens you
want to make sure your loved ones are
protected that is why legal zone
continues to provide a reliable way for
everyone to set up the right estate plan
without leaving your home it starts with
finding the answers to your questions do
you need a last will and testament or a
living trust of course you do did you
bring people into the world are you
married do you want to make sure they're
going to be okay you know in case you're
going down the street on your [__]
Segway you lose control right and you
slam into a bunch of people not wearing
masks sunbathing in a park
you get CTE and [__] The Cove it all
at the same time it starts with finding
their answers to your questions do you
need a last will and testament of living
trusts are ya are you read that I
already read that I'm I apologize
what about anime advanced health care
directive and what's a power of attorney
attorney thankfully you don't have to
figure everything out on your own legal
zooms online resources make it easier to
gets added if you need to speak to an
attorney
they're independent attorney networks is
there to guide and advise you Legal Zoom
is not isn't a law firm so you won't
have to worry about expensive billable
hours adding up take an important step
for your family today go to
legalzoom.com
to get started on a last wheel living
trusts and more guys i got to tell you
this if you haven't done that if you're
married if you have a wife you got kids
and all of that type of stuff I I kind
of fought it because I don't know some
about guys dealing with their mortality
it's the greatest feeling afterwards
when that's done when it's done you know
unless you're married to a psycho and
she's the beneficiary then you know you
got to start making all your own meals
or find out how you can speak to an
attorney for advice on the right estate
plan
egle somewhere life meets legal alright
oh look who's here dude do me undies me
undies you don't really like that chick
do do-do-do beyond these beyond these
you were thinking with your dick
now you have to write a cheesy song you
got to sing it for the rest of your
career it's gonna seem long when you say
those [__] words la dee da dee da ba
dooby doo [__] me undies at least your
balls will feel nice and soft this is
weird thing that I have about people
that write hit music where I feel bad
for them if they only have one because
then they got to sing that [__] song
every goddamn show where if you're the
Rolling Stones you know they can kind of
take a couple of [__] you know like
Roy and I can't play satisfaction again
it's just no satisfied satisfactory to
me Mick
alright ah summertime dreaming these are
the day when visions of sunshine and
surf danced through our heads probably
now more than ever as we collectively
mold into our couches but we know that's
not it that's not what's happening
that's not what's happening you got at
least 15 [__] percent of the
population is acting like it's not even
going on alright they need to be but we
got to get we got to keep the dream
alive me um bees me undies is committed
to the cause by keeping you in a
constant stream of uninterrupted dream
inducing undie comfort how do you reach
this uninterrupted state of comfort you
ask with the membership from me undies
as your undie collection grows your
laundry time lessons and a adulting gets
that much easy easier what is adulting
ad ult ing that's a word plus a
membership comes with site-wide savings
early access and free shipping
oh and zero reasons to leave your house
just grab these new undies off the porch
and get right back on to that summertime
dreamin the undies are made from micro
Modell an irresistible soft sustainable
fabric
that encases your nether regions in a
cloud of comfort it's magically made
from trees another reason to give them a
hug me undies are offered in a range of
sizes from extra small to 4 XL alright
yeah yeah look at that
all the way up to pornstar baby dick up
to [__] pornstar me undies has a
great offer from my listeners for any
time first purchase you can get 15% off
in free shipping you got to give this
you got to give this super softness a
try especially because they have a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
with to get you 15 percent off your
first order free shipping and hundreds
in satisfaction guarantee you go to me
undies calm / bird that's me Indies calm
/ burr right one more here we all shop
online a lot but did you know you can
make online shopping even better with
honey honey is the free online shopping
tool that offers that saves you money
online honey
automatically finds the best promo code
sorry about that last one and applies
them to your cart which makes online
shopping finally feel as easy as it's
going it's supposed to be
imagine you're shopping on one of your
favorite sites Target Best Buy Sephora
Macy's eBay Etsy walmat etc when you
check it when you checkout this little
box drops down and all you have to do is
click apply coupons wait a few seconds
for it to scan for every promo code on
the internet I wish every old lady would
do this watch the prices drop instead of
taking them out with their [__] hand
shaking and [__] and you just going on
man this poor woman do I help her out I
hate myself I'm feeling impatient what
am I going to start wearing a housecoat
users love
honey that's why it's it's has over a
hundred thousand-plus five-star reviews
on the google chrome store not using
honey is literally passing up free money
it's free to use as and installs in just
a few seconds plus it's backed by PayPal
so you know you can trust it get honey
for free at join honeycomb / / that's
joint honey calm
/ / oh by the way see the season 4
trailer for f is for family I posted
that on my Instagram gram gram gram I
also posted that on my Twitter and also
this this week I also posted the trailer
for the king of Staten Island the Pete
Davidson Marisa Tomei Steve Buscemi
directed by Judd Apatow movie said they
talked myself into a corner that that is
is gonna be coming out on June 12th
guess what they both come out June 12th
you can have an overdose of freckles on
June 12th and here's the deal I need you
guys to watch this [__] alright I hope
that you like him I think they're both
[__] hilarious the Pete Davidson
movies getting ridiculous ridiculously
positive feedback I'm very happy about
that because I loved working with all of
those guys and watch out for Ricky Velez
- he [__] crushes it in that movie
stand-up comedian who I got to meet on
that thing it's a great time seems like
a lifetime ago with all this [__]
[__] we're dealing with so June 12th
it's gonna be streaming all of this [__]
is streaming f is for family on Netflix
and then I'll have all the information
where you can watch the king of Staten
Island it's I saw an early cut of it
it's a really really good movie all
right I'm putting that out there
it has my stamp of approval I wouldn't I
wouldn't [__] you alright
it's just a piece of [__] I would be
like a comes out to twelve what's up
with the weather how would she change
the subject but this is a really good
movie and f is for family season four
with the great Jonathan banks playing
the part of Frank Murphy's father and
they don't have the best relationships
so there's and there's another one so
it's kind of cool they're both coming
out on the same day overdose of old
freckles all right now I got some I got
a promo of a wandering show one we who
does all the advertising here on this
podcast so there's a podcast that's on
the Wonder II website here business wars
all right I'm gonna actually listen to
this Amazon verse Walmart please use
your own voice these points are to guide
you don't read verbatim don't rush
Jesus Christ III feel like that was only
put on my copy
all right I'm reading all of this well
I'm supposed to improv and something
that I don't know about I'm discovering
this with my listeners this is part of
the the magic of my reads all right now
I want to tell you guys about a weekly
podcast from wand recalled business wars
each season digs deep into the greatest
corporate rivalries of all time oh
that's [__] great what a great idea
for a podcast think Facebook for a
snapchat that wasn't even a fight was it
or Nike verse adidas that wasn't a good
matchup Chevy versus Ford that's still
going on our Starbucks first Dunkin
Donuts on each episode they give you an
inside look at what inspired
entrepreneurs to take risks that drove
their companies to new heights or into
the ground I think me and my lovely wife
would enjoy that in their newest season
they cover Amazon versus Walmart
business wars follows these two enormous
retails as they Duke it out for retail
dominance I love how they just can't be
satisfied with being multi billionaires
chances are you have ordered something
from these two companies while you've
been stuck at home for the last month
more Americans than ever are buying
things online 96% of American
shop online and almost half of those
purchases take place on just one website
Amazon yeah maybe they started this
covet [__] huh
who stood the game is all these [__]
businesses are gonna go out of [__]
business here 90% of Americans live
within 10 miles of a Walmart store so
they've got the distribution network to
go toe-to-toe with Amazon when it comes
to getting you what you want delivered
to your door fast this is like you know
when they do make those phony YouTube
videos
alligator versus great white shark or be
you know [__] bear versus gorilla who
would win this is kind of cool man now
Walmart and Amazon are two of the
biggest companies out there but how big
is big did you did you know before
Amazon became Amazon they only sold
books they were originally called
Cadabra that sounds like a brassiere for
somebody with three nipples the Walton
family owns Walmart that owns Walmart
are some of the wealthiest people in the
country with a combined personal fortune
of over two hundred billion dollars
workers inside both companies are rising
up arguing that the retail Giants are
failing to protect them from the
coronavirus prioritizing the bottom line
over workers health business wars Wars
looks at how much both how they are both
more powerful than ever but also more
vulnerable business wars takes you it's
amazing how this is like the [__] that
why unions started because of not take
the bottom line was more important than
workers health business wars takes you
behind the scenes as these companies
grow from small-town startups to global
powerhouses I never understood why
businesses like this didn't let their
employees share more in the wealth like
I can't imagine how much fun it would be
to be that successful with your business
and you're making billions and billions
of dollars and then just like you just
share the wealth with your [__]
employees
like one of the things gonna happen
everybody's just gonna [__] quit if I
was running one of those [__] things
I would I would say like alright here's
the deal
this is like whatever whatever amount of
money works this amount of million I'm
gonna give to each one of you employees
or whatever there's hundred thousand
whatever you can afford to [__] do
all right but before I give it to you
you we have a free course on how to
manage money that you had that's
required and you have to take these
tests along the way and pass them okay
cuz it's gonna break my heart if I'm
going to give you this [__] money and
you're gonna piss through it at a
goddamn casino or whatever the [__] it
is you doing all right now once I give
it to you it is your money you get who
is it hey what's going on you want you
want me to be goofy that's a new thing
you're doing that all day you want to go
play Tibo music you need to do dance
class in music class okay
alright beautiful look at you two angels
you guys enjoy your breakfast this
morning like I'm getting that in there
that I made you breakfast you say what a
Dada Dada you say what a husband see
that everybody I am a good guy what do
you want to do today t-ball and swimming
you want to ride in your tricycle are
you getting too big for okay well we
were wondering when we were gonna
announce that we were expecting a son
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you just let the whole cat out of the
bag
yeah yeah well you know I taught my kid
everything other than how to keep her
mouth shut you got breakfast surprised
if I seemed a little on edge is cuz my
wife is like eight and a half months
pregnant all right all right well there
you go
it's about as organic an announcement as
you can have wait way to steal our
thunder with that all right go enjoy
your dance class all right the town
crier all right business wars take you
takes you behind the scenes as the
companies grow from small town startups
to global powerhouses
oh what I would say was I would send
everybody in to what do you call it
you're like a business class or whatever
and then I would I would have a clear
conscience afterwards you passed the
test you learned about money you know
how to handle it and then if you [__] up
your money that's on you I don't
understand why they do what they do to
people like you know I just don't get I
just don't get treating employees like
[__] and having them drive all night
long and they're slamming into people
like I mean who wasn't that well that's
what happened to Tracy Morgan and all of
those guys it's a driver from one of
those companies [__] driving all
[__] night long trying to make a
deadline or some [__] right isn't that
what happened allegedly I don't know and
I want to get sued here anyways business
wars is hosted by David Brown who
brought you we crashed the outcome of
these battles shape what we buy and how
we live
subscribe to business Wars on Apple
podcasts Spotify or listen ad-free on
wondering Plus
all right oh no wow I just the first
[__] the first [__] in the first
[__] question of the week order right
in somebody wrote wrong one wrong Tara
Reid you dope Biden wasn't hanging
around the set of American Pie Tara Reid
Rea de was one of his aides love you
love the podcast oh I thought it was the
other Tara Reid I was wondering why what
the [__] he was not actually I wasn't
they'd made sense to me he's a powerful
guy
alright 2000 years ago Plato burned
comedians and painters alike dear bill
Burris tall
I just finished listening to the Monday
morning podcasts of you and a couple of
painters going at each other's throats
after listening to the podcast I took my
20 minute work break and continued my
reading of the Republic of by Plato oh
oh is that what she is that what you do
during your [__] break you see what
he uh oh oh oh we got a scholar here
there was no reason to let me know that
this is what you were doing okay let's
give you the praise Wow you know with
everybody glued to their laptops and
their iPads and the flat screens it's
really great to see that somebody is
using their 20-minute break to not only
read a book to rereading on the Republic
of Plato and that's PLA t oh not this
[__] that you [__] you know if you
leave the cap off it dries out in the
game's over it was so it just so happens
that one of the first paragraph I read
was Plato essentially [__] on both
comedians and painters at the same time
now that right there sounds like a funny
[__] dude albeit in the context of
this page
is talking about poets and painters of
art but if you pretend he's injecting in
this argument
it's absolutely but if you pretend he's
in interjecting in this argument it's
absolutely hilarious what are the
chances I'd be listening to your podcast
and be reading the passages of a 2000
year old book at the same time anyway
here is the passage in the question in
question I tried to switch the words of
poet to comedian so you can get where
I'm coming from all right now that I've
made fun of this guy this is actually
really interesting and and now we may
fairly take the comedian and place him
by the side of the painter for he is
like him in two ways first in as much as
the comedian's creations have an
inferior degree of truth oh yeah guilty
guilty as charged
in this I say he is like the painter and
he is also like the painter in being
concerned with an inferior part of the
soul and therefore we shall be right and
refusing to admit him into a
well-ordered state because he awakens
and nourishes and strengthens the
feelings and impairs the reasons the
reason yeah this is why they never used
to let actors and entertainers or
whatever become politicians because they
thought they could fool you they didn't
realize that that's just a public
speaking trick make you feel your fields
rather than be like well this guy is the
host of a reality show and has had a
bunch of failed businesses why would we
want this running the country
you [__] liberal smash cut one of the
ways to beat the coronavirus is to take
household cleaner and inject it into
your body there's still people arguing
for Trump it's my favorite [__] it that
doesn't well number one reasons I wish
this pandemic wasn't going aside from
[__] people living week to week small
businesses and all that good [__] is I
just watch we'll be on the road and talk
to trump supporters be like please
explain to me how you're still behind a
guy who said that [__] please anyways
let me continue a
as in a city when the evil are permitted
to have authority and the good are put
out of the way so in the soul of a man
as we maintain the initiative the aro
imitative poet aka comedian implants an
evil Constitution for he indulges the
irrational nature which has no
discernment of greater of greater and
less but thinks the same thing at one
time great and add another small this
guy was a [__] idiot this guy sounds
like I'm conservative [__] trying to
shut down the arts he's a man you I just
call Plato a [__] I did he is a
manufacturer of images and is very far
removed from the truth Wow but
politicians are if you pick like I don't
know what background he wanted more of a
business background he goes if that [__]
doesn't burn I don't know what does much
love and stay safe no I didn't take that
personally that kind of just sounds like
modern-day rhetoric you know what I
understood what you was saying but I got
more fascinated with this halfway
through as this guy I think maybe
because he thought so logically that he
just thought art was like frivolous he
wasn't in the metaphors or [__] like
that I don't know I don't know anything
about this guy but that just kind of
came off like conservative pamphlet from
like a week ago
but I got to tell you I mean he's not
wrong and he's not wrong
we had Jimmy Carter in there putting
solar panels on the White House saying
we were addicted to oil keeping us out
of the [__] Middle East and then what
happened then we got an actor in there
next he [__] took him down [__]
suck the [__] dick of the oil
companies and now here we are lazy Jay
Cutler I'm not saying it's just him
because everybody else was doing that
Jimmy Carter was what well when are they
gonna do the biopic on Jimmy Jimmy
Carter when they gonna do that there's
no way to do it because they'll just say
just Hollywood liberalism but that guy
was seriously is seriously a you know if
every politician was like him I don't
know it's why I like Bernie Sanders I
like that guy I like guys like that
whether they lean right or left I just
like people that give a [__] cuz there's
some Republicans out there that are
actually talking about the little guy in
and you know it seems anyways that it's
coming from the heart not just telling
people what they want to hear lazy Jay
Cutler hey Billy Bolshevik since you're
a lefty and I love it Bolshevik
Bolshevik I don't know what that means
is that [__] Slovakian for
left-handed wanted to take wanted to get
your take on Jay Cutler's now ex-wife
calling him lazy for not wanting to get
a job
the man played in the NFL for 11 years
and led the league in sacks taken in
2010 with 52 meanwhile his privileged
wife has been nothing but a reality show
star her whole life and you used that to
start a shitty fashion line probably
with his money well that's a pretty good
guess considering they don't pay those
reality TV stars [__] unless they're
able to spin it into other stuff like I
know Pauly D is makin Bank as a DJ which
makes me really happy because I [__]
root for all of these people man I don't
want to see you [__] get on one of
these shows become this person and then
they make all the money you don't make
any money so I was very happy like when
I would back when you used to do live
shows when I would go to Vegas I'll go
to Atlantic City and I'd see a billboard
for Pauly D I'd be like that's [__]
cool good for him got Van Gogh go make a
bunch of [__] money Cutler made over
a hundred million when he was a player
he needs to work like you need to do
like you do with your Netflix Millions
okay that last part was just [__]
with you since I know you have a soft
spot for that you earn that dough that's
right and I don't begrudge anybody that
earned their money
you know that's a [__] people who do
that to people
are losers who never went after a
[__] dream that's their thing so then
what happens is is when you're going
after your dream early on they [__] on
it and then when you make a don't go
forgetting the day to day to day and
then when they get into financial
straits they try to make you feel guilty
because you worked your ass off yeah you
got money for gifts to around Christmas
must be nice
must all that [__] that's all it's
all that that's that blue-collar guilt
that you can [__] turn it up sideways
and shove it straight up your candy ass
I have no guilt
cheers and go [__] yourself your
daughter has the cutest voice I've ever
heard and you're lucky to have such a
beautiful family yes I am a growing
family all right let's look this it Jay
Cutler open the link get Dinka Dinka
Dinka Dinka dink open the link open the
link Donal Annette denna Linda Kristin
Cavallari divorcing lazy Jim Cutler
because he was unmotivated
oh boy Kristin Cavallari is divorcing
Jay Cutler in part because she's sick of
the former NFL star lying around the
house page six is told the hill star
Mary Cutler in 2013 when he was a
quarterback with the Chicago Bears and
we're told she thought he was lined up
for a demanding career as us and we're
told she thought he was lined up for a
demanding career as a sports broadcaster
after he hung up his cleats but sources
say that after his broadcasting career
faltered the ever ambitious Cavallari
who announced in late April the pair
were splitting found him unmotivated and
even lazy while he found that he had a
penchant for hanging out with their
three kids and menagerie of animals on
their Tennessee farm she was growing
increasingly impatient
with him he was supposed to take this
big job at Fox Sports and have a life
after football that would get him up off
the couch and do something set an
insider instead he backed out this is
three years ago and joined the Miami
Dolphins that didn't pan out well and he
was left with no TV gig until she got
the show for them 2017 after eight
seasons with the bear currently retired
to pursue a broadcasting career then
came out of retirement and spent one
injury marg seasons with the dolphins
the couple moved on to star in the Erie
allottee series very calm Cavallari
oh boy it's her last name oh brother
brother well he picked the e picked her
which follows her jewelry business and
their family and has so far aired for
three seasons the source added the
Cavallari views herself as a very
polished and put together in color as
this lazy unmotivated guy Cutler has
late lately been mulling another attempt
at a broadcasting career and according
to her their reality show has had offers
from CBS and ESPN when she announced the
breakup Cavallari wrote an Instagram
with great sadness after ten years
together we have come to a loving
conclusion to get a divorce she said
it's just a situation of two people
growing apart reps didn't get back to us
well I mean if that's what she says
she's not saying lazy I don't know I
don't know what the [__] she said I have
no [__] idea it's not like she's
laying around doing nothing though she
has a jewelry line she's been a reality
show stars she's going going going and
maybe it worked when they were both at
work I don't [__] know I have no idea
but either way that sucks when that
happens especially when there's kids
involved I mean you know I don't I don't
know what I don't know I'm not gonna
[__] I don't know her from Adam I
don't know him it's a sad thing I hope
the kids are alright there you go sorry
you wanted me to do the old gold-digging
[__] thing I've done that a million
[__] times
alright advise quarantine break up
I mean there's a lot of football fans
out there that would say that Jay Cutler
is lazy I don't and I wouldn't I would
all right god bless them both I hope
they come to an a me a couple [__]
thing and they think about the kids
first all right advise quarantine break
up oh boy hey hey there Billy beef
curtains I have decided it's time to
break up my girlfriend of two years the
only reason I haven't already are that
my parents love her and I don't want to
send her into a downward spiral of
depression see what happens when you
choose what other people want rather
than what you want anyways what she has
a history of I am well versed in your
podcast breakup advice so I know that
those are not valid reasons to stay in
our relationship things were already bad
before quarantine so I know that The
Cove it isn't the issue here however how
does your advice translate translate to
these capital letters uncertain times we
do not live together nice
we are both staying with our families
beautiful we go to the same College with
the same major which is how we met how
do you advise executing the break-up in
the quarantine do I still go for the
in-person delivery or can I get away
with the FaceTime call and how do you
advise dealing with being around each
other at college whenever we go back
you're the best bill thanks for all you
do well usually I would say do it face
to face can you break up with there from
6 feet away well wait a minute have you
guys seen each other at all during the
quarantine because if you have been that
I would try to do it face to face I
would just have a mask on to hide your
smile when you break up with her kidding
yeah dude just [__] do it just do it
her issues are not your issues because
somebody's [__] going to take it hard
and take it bad or they're depressed
that's not your [__] problem all
right if you really were in love then
this was the right [__] persons none
of this [__] would be issues but if you
do not
with them you're just wasting their
[__] time which is the most
depressing [__] thing you can do to
somebody all right and then how do i
advise dealing with being around each
other at college when you go back I
would just be friendly be pleasant don't
get drawn back into it if she just if
she goes the you know women do that
thing where they they do the Vengeance I
gotta get him back I got to start
[__] his friend
I gotta spread rumors or whatever the
[__] she's gonna do just you know if she
does do any of that [__] just you know
and your friends Ellie she said this
this and this about you shrug your
shoulders be like I mean she misses my
dick I mean I don't know what to tell
you
you know no I don't yes my thing is
whenever I broke up with somebody I
always tried to stay away from them to
give them a chance to just do whatever
and then also to just try to avoid as
much as that but you know the [__] that
women can do but you definitely should
break up with her if that's what you
want to do you should definitely [__]
do it and her being depressed and all of
that [__] is not your [__] problem it
just isn't alright
her majesty [__] question hey Billie
burnt tits I didn't know what that means
my buddy has been taking been asking
this same question at parties before
corona
the answer always seems to be pretty
evenly split and causes some lively
debates so here it is do you think the
Queen of England Her Majesty Queen
Elizabeth has given 50 [__] in her
life it can be the same dick just 50
[__] total I said no way isn't it
illegal to touch the Queen yeah I doubt
she's out there looking for a dick to
gag on please keep ripping on painters
they're always in the [__] way on the
job sites
I'm sure they feel the same about you um
now whatever your vocation is let's see
here fifty [__] yeah you know those
[__] rich white people are all freaks
she's probably sucked a dick wearing a
goat head I don't know why wouldn't she
50 she's like a hundred and thirty she
gave one [__] every nine years she'd
still be above now that wouldn't work
whatever yeah yeah I think she did I
absolutely think she did I can't even
believe you're debating that unless her
first husband died really quickly and
she never got over it never dated again
I don't know that's a weird question I
can't believe that sparked lively debate
I'm trying to remember who the [__] she
is is she still alive I don't who gives
a [__] all right overrated underrated
overrated from a lady she absolutely did
she she's the mom of Charles right I
think all [__] around and then they
[__] get a mistress and then they
[__] leave and then they get
excommunicated out of the thing and then
they get a beg their way back then they
go to [__] Canada yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely you're in a
[__] bubble everybody looking at you
you're sitting there sweating it every
day at what point is this whole thing
gonna go away with this royalty [__]
they're gonna take this house and never
had a job my life makes you nervous
stress you know sex gets rid of stress
yes but she north of 500 [__]
all right overrated underrated from a
lady hey Billy ballad bangin Baldy locks
I've been married for 14 years and my
husband and I are in our late 40s
hands-down overrated is sleeping in the
same goddamn bed with your spouse every
night after time and aging my husband
started to snore he probably put on
weight I'm a lighter sleep
so I begin to crawl into the guest room
for a few uninterrupted hours of sleep
this didn't go over well at first but
the nose strips taping tapping his leg
with my foot or poking him didn't help
with the snoring either one night a huge
heated argument erupted in the guest
room he stormed we have made up we've
since made up however we are still
sleeping in separate rooms that's great
and it's the best goddamn sleep we've
both had in a long time that's perfect
who made this rule that spouses have to
sleep side by side every night I don't
think it's in the Bible is it there are
so many other ways to connect with your
partner totally overrated enjoy every
moment of quarantine with your baby girl
it goes by so fast thanks for listening
and go [__] yourself I 100% agree with
that 100% back in my booze and days I'd
come to bed hammered and I would snore
and my wife would go in the guest room
and I never had a problem with it and
you know my wife isn't a snore off but
if I get overly tired I I can or if I or
if I weigh more if I'm in the buck
eighties instead of the 170s of the buck
60s I can snore a little bit or if I'm
overly tired and that's a terrible thing
to do to somebody it's just in ruins
they're in there aren't you ruining the
next day of their life and that could be
the last day everybody okay there we go
that is the that is the podcast
everybody god bless you thanks for
listening June 12th f is for family June
12th the king of Staten Island double
shot of old freckles all right don't
sleep on your old
NFL knowledge there your history all
right I'm gonna read some Plato this guy
is very interesting to me I bet he was
liberal as [__] back then maybe that
wasn't considered conservative I have no
idea I don't even know where it was he
was he in green I got like a Plato lamb
I'm not gonna start reading Plato
there's no way to bring up that you read
Plato without some of you like out right
all right we get it we get it you know I
don't like reading that old [__] because
there's it's like in English but it's
written weird like Shakespeare it's just
like like I don't know what the [__]
they're talking about you know it must
be the amazing day when finally you get
all of that [__] and you can actually
sit down and read those stories but in
like Romeo and Juliet it's like a
[__] chick flick isn't it I don't
know that's probably not that's not fair
is it because nothing else was done oh I
do I didn't talk about Little Richard
Little Richard couple of things here
rest in peace Little Richard without a
doubt one of the greatest who ever did
it and just I mean I would just do the
first rock star I'd say Little Richard
and Elvis were the first four they would
like that The Blueprint and I don't do
that [__] oh you took from this guy and
he took my Bubba everybody takes from
everybody
it's so [__] oh I'm so sick of that
argument that all music comes from the
Blues in jazz it's just like and what
were they listening to there wasn't any
music before them like the ignorance of
that and not giving credit to [__]
morphing into other stuff I just don't
understand that like that would be like
me as a white person taking credit for
lowriders because Henry Ford is the
Delta blues of [__] making cars the
[__] out of here that's some Latino [__]
they came up with it it's [__]
amazing white people never would have
done that you know
I saw somebody was Southie
Jerry Lee Lewis stole everything but but
it's like you don't think he was also
listening to Hank Williams I'm supposed
to sit here and think Jerry Lee Lewis
was playing chopsticks bow but did but
though but there but and then [__]
[Music]
what's-his-face comes along and then
immediately he [__] Little Richard
comes along and then all of a sudden in
one year he learns how to play piano
like that I mean they well they
everybody listens to [__] everybody
and it's such itself such I saw that on
Twitter it's just I can't somebody just
died and you can just say he was one of
the greatest of all time without
[__] on somebody else
it's [__] horrific they all they all
serve a [__] purpose they're all
[__] amazing and they're all way more
talented than me so I'm not gonna
criticize any of them all right god
bless anybody who comes up with
something [__] creative haven't said
that dull I mean I mean that guy's at
the easies at the top I'd have to say
that guys is that the [__] top as far
as the performance the voice the
screaming all of that I mean just and I
know that his drummer I forget who his
drama was this well I forget what song I
used to know all of this [__] when I was
psycho into music there's a beginning of
one of the Little Richard's songs and
it's the drumming thing that's the
beginning of the Led Zeppelin rock and
roll and Bonham was playing it because
he was a fan and I guess Jimmy Page came
in and said hey what's that he goes all
it's this Little Richard stay a little
Richard thing and I don't know why Led
Zeppelin did that to God let's just
let's just take that and then they
didn't give anybody credit that's why
they got into so much [__] trouble
because what they did with all the blues
songs is they made them completely
[__] different but like you have to
still say that this is a cover of that
song they eventually [__] did it but
I don't know I don't know why they chose
to do that but anyways plowing ahead
here everybody [__] takes from
everybody you know my nuts
and my nuts here why did I get involved
in this [__] argument
it's just when everybody takes them
everybody but one is in control of the
[__] historical narration that's when
it becomes bad that's what I don't agree
with I don't agree with people not
getting [__] credit but I also don't
agree with saying that like just one
overcorrecting and then just saying okay
this side just did everything and then
this side didn't do [__] it's just like
I said it's the [__] lowrider analogy
either agree with it you don't I don't
give a [__] I don't know why I brought
this up it was a great podcast and I
probably [__] it up here in the end
all right go [__] yourselves this is
pandemic bill signing off telling you to
if you have I can't say what I want to
say I if I can't say what I want to say
here I know there's a lot of people out
there that have weapons that are not
lethal and I was going to suggest using
them on a certain maskless group of the
population but I don't condone that
alright go [__] yourselves and I'll
check in on Thursday do not do what I
just suggested comedic ly okay I'm not
advocating that by
you